have i made a joke about danica patrick
danica patrick i go holy smokes i said
she's good look and now all the nascar
drivers are going to have to have
windshield wipers on the inside of the
car
i think another one is about pull setter
but i can't remember how it went on
danica's on the pole again you were the
grand marshal and i was also doing
something we were the two big guests at
the big place
louisiana i think it was you went up did
your deal then i mean you said a couple
of jokes about me and then i went up and
did my deal then a couple of natick
patrick jokes i come across an article
from that thing
and it was some gossip column
in hollywood and it said
it said
could there be a new romance in the
making
and it said
and it said the chemistry between danica
patrick and everything
and i was i was like oh my gosh i don't
even remember this article i showed my
wife and we just got into laughing about
it
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is dan whitney and
you're gonna go wait a second who's that
and then i'm gonna say larry the cable
guy and you're gonna go oh i know who
that is
well his real name is dan so
the beginning of the conversation was
all about dan and larry and how they
when larry was born and the relationship
with larry and who dan is but you know
the beginning was so much about just it
was just dan
and um my goodness he is a really really
really compassionate guy he's a really
kind guy of course he's funny but he's
also really smart and thoughtful and i
just loved the the first half of this
conversation was so
so such a different vibe than i feel
like i've really seen and heard out of
him and and i just loved it uh he's uh
he's obviously an extremely successful
comedian he
uh was on the blue collar comedy tour
back in the early 2000s with other
famous names he has tons of comedy
albums that have come out and been
successful and i later on in the episode
joked about all the things that he sells
on his website i mean it's everything
from like knives to underwear and bloody
larry mix and all kinds of stuff and i
was like do you have a line in the sand
like i'm not going to
sell this uh but what it skipped to
really quick was that all the things
that he sells on his website go to the
get her done foundation and they've
donated
over seven million dollars so far to
charities from all of those sales um
from the things that he sells on the
website so
uh what an amazing guy super cool super
funny super thoughtful really smart and
i think you're gonna fall in love with
dan
today and you're all you probably
already love larry but but you're gonna
really meet dan today and uh he's a
wonderful human and of course if you
love his larry character and all of the
funny things that he does for his job uh
he's touring which i'm sure that we can
all say thank god for touring whether
it's music or comedy or anything um
let's get out there and and support
these people who've been
you know whose lives depend on on doing
that and now maybe larry slash dan's
doesn't but still we love to see him out
doing his thing enjoy the episode you
can you know what you can uh do larry
the cable guy but we're friends so dan
the rest of the time
i mean people that's a crazy thing
because people call me just larry i've
been larry since 1993.
so
um all my friends call me dan people
that think they know me call me danny
um for some reason i don't know it's
weird but i've been larry the cable guy
they call me even when i do like
like i'm doing this big free show down
here at the lead center in lincoln
nebraska so they do this whole thing and
they call me larry the cable guy they
never once called me by my real name
it's like why are people calling me
obviously it's a character i mean how
you know what i mean so stupid but no
you don't know that though people don't
know that i didn't really even know that
like i just thought it was larry and
somehow you became the cable guy that's
how good of an actual guy i mean these
are really like you know these are
logical questions in my head
that's how good of an actor i am
that's right right
they always tell me that like my movie
is like i'm such a bad actor and critics
always hammer me he's acting you can't
actually well evidently i'm act i act
pretty good because you actually think i
am this like a cable guy that like i
mean come on
i mean people are complete morons
have we started the interview of course
we started the interview from the point
in time where you were looking at it
really close so i soft start i put
people off a little bit but i kind of
soft start and um mostly it's because i
like people to feel comfortable and i
know that you can be very uptight so i
wanted to really like roll into this
easily i'm real difficult
no
dan's fine i mean you know it's really
crazy because i've been doing this now
um
i hit nationally with larry the cable
guy doing my character in like 1997
98
you know doing clubs everywhere and then
when i hit the blue collar tour then it
was everywhere
but i've been doing this literally so
since so that's like 21 years
just after blue collar started 22 years
and then like five years before that on
radio but it's like i've done hundreds
of interviews i did 60 minutes
interview i'm
out of character i'm one of the only
casino comedians ever featured on 60
minutes
and
i did it completely out of character
uh i've done i mean i've done so many
interviews out of character and people's
i don't
you know it's not my fans it's people
that just like which are very few
obviously because i got great fan base
but
they you know people that don't like me
particularly like critics you know how
critics are they don't like it they like
it and
they have this image of you
and they just keep putting out this fake
you know they've never been to my shows
they've never they just i don't know
it's it's crazy so it's like
my fans know for the most part
that it's a character now when i first
started some of them might not have but
as i went along and i did interviews and
so forth and so on at some point i think
some of them got to the point wait a
second this is so outrageous this has
got to be fake right this is so
outrageous
i think the thing that confuses some
people
is
i'm uh
i'm not like i'm a real country kid you
know i grew up on a in a town of 1200 in
the southeast corner of nebraska i grew
up raised in hogs
um my goal in life was to be a uh
cattle auctioneer
um that's what i wanted to do so i'm a
i'm a bona fide grade a country kid then
i met foxworthy
and when i started you know
i went to college in georgia and then i
met foxworthy so i've been around
southerners
literally my whole life up to
after the age of 15 at 16.
and so i just picked up the accent
so it's like when i hang out with my
buddies yeah that's how all my buddies
always talk and you just pick it up you
do it's so easy like being in nascar and
kind of you kind of end up y'all i mean
like there's at least
at least in the vocabulary there are new
words or additional words you know
it's so easy to pick it up
oh absolutely so it's you know people
don't understand that but i mean just
look at people that like my wife's from
wisconsin
um
she talks pretty
normal now because we live in nebraska
but all of her all the rest of her
family they're all yeah so we were all
you know that was so like dick trickle
so you know
so um that's how i kind of am if i spend
any time in wisconsin
uh on vacation i start to sound like
that so if i go back to florida where i
live some of the time i'm back in the
accent because that's where all my
friends are
so it's it's it's crazy so i literally
can talk normal like i'm talking to you
now
and then uh
for about uh
five weeks in the summer
i'm uh i'm i turn into dick trickle
because that's who i'm around
and then um
in the winter time most of the winter
when i go to florida i go from me to
dick trickle back to me toward burton
yeah so you know so that's that's uh you
know that's
i tell everybody i defy you to go to
florida move to florida as a and hang
out with people that are completely
southern for any period of time
and you're living proof you pick up the
accent you pick up certain words
and you can't you can't get away from it
yeah
i i agree you pick things up but what
i'm hearing is like these so many
different you pick up so many different
uh
words and accents and
maybe even mannerisms or the way you
live who knows
and i think about the fact that you're a
comedian and you
you have these
you have these roles you have you know
you're the cable guy which i do want to
hear by the way what it sounds like when
you're larry the cable guy versus
dan or versus any other character i'm
curious because i want people to
understand when you are larry the cable
guy versus not and maybe it's just in
the jokes but maybe it's in the accent
but also i'm thinking you make people
feel comfortable
and so you know you grew up
you know i mean from what i understand
you know your dad wasn't always the
easiest on you and
you know you you know comedy came in at
a young age and and i wonder if maybe
there's some level some like more
psychological sort of perspective where
you mold into your environment because
it makes people feel comfortable
oh absolutely you know
um comedy gave me confidence
i never really had a lot of confidence
and comedy gave me confidence because
when once you got on stage and you
started doing it
um you're not good at first but you
stick to it then all of a sudden you get
up and you you're in control of an
audience and
and you're making some people laugh and
all of a sudden a pretty girl comes up
and starts talking to you and it give
then you get more and more confidence i
think that's why a lot of times
later when i did the character it gave
me uh it
it gave me an opportunity to
kind of
um
do something
in another persona
you know that made me more comfortable
so when i started doing larry the cable
guy it's like i was just saying said to
somebody the other day i automatically
if i meet somebody for the first time or
i'm in a group of people for the first
time i automatically
resort to and of course though somebody
will call me larry or whatever but it's
kind of a defense mechanism i feel more
comfortable
in a crowd of people going
hey what's going on y'all everybody hey
did y'all ever had a birthday you know
uh oh yeah zipper last week we supper
you know and i just and i just naturally
talk that way because
i've had so much confidence doing that
that it kind of just
i eased into i eased into things a lot
better then you know an hour another
conversation
i'm back to my so i'm back to being me
and just talking like me but when i
first
when i first start in certain situations
that's how i start talking and it's
subconscious i mean i don't even do it
on purpose it's like my buddy called me
the other day my buddy brad ward from
sanford florida he called me where i
used to live in sanford and
you know he was one of my buddies i grew
up with so he's real southern you know
and so
i was just talking to my wife like this
normal we're having a conversation brad
called and the first thing she hears me
do is go hey what's up brad
no he ain't calling me but if he calls
you know tell him i got two of so just
you know whatever he needs to do
you know and i literally had this 15
minute conversation with my buddy brad
and i hung up and my wife said you know
you were in character for 15 minutes
i didn't even realize it it's just
that's how brad talks and he's my friend
and that's kind of like you know our
little group thing we got going
so yeah it's it's pretty crazy i really
turn it on
if it's somebody
that uh you know because i i was born in
nebraska but i grew up in the south
you know i grew up in florida which is
the south whether people want to believe
it or not
and depending on what part you're in
and so all my friends were southern you
know because i was a country kid i hung
out with the people that had livestock
and horses and cattle so
um
they were all very southern
so it's uh if i ever if i'm somewhere
here say if i'm somewhere just where i'm
at in lincoln and somebody will come up
and go hey larry man we're big fans man
we we've seen you down you know and they
got a southern accent i'll go
hey man i appreciate it where y'all from
and they'll tell me oh yeah you know we
spent time down there and
you know it just it just happens and i
subconsciously do it i don't do it just
because i'm trying to fake somebody out
i do it because it's just me it's just
that's what comes out of me
uh i think it makes me feel safer it
makes me feel uh
more connected to the person
um
because i'll be honest i i really i
i didn't have a lot of confidence when i
was a kid and i built my confidence
through the character larry the cable
guy that enabled me to be able to go on
stage
in front of thousands of people
and tell jokes
uh and it and it so yeah it's really
helped me come out of my shell and
be able to talk to people with
confidence and
why weren't you confident i mean clearly
you're a friendly guy you're a funny guy
you're
you're an empathetic kind person which
because all you're you're really just
mirroring people so that's a very you
know that makes people feel really
comfortable so what was it what was it
about your childhood that wasn't that
didn't make you have confidence well no
it's just you know some kids grow up
they don't think they're good at
anything you and your mind think you're
good at something but you're scared to
try it for fear that you're not good at
it what happens if you failed
was there a punishment
no not at all if you got bad grades did
you come home no
i got it
i got bad grades because i was goof off
and i just never really tried no look i
know you get that look my dad was uh i
love my dad my dad was my dad i mean i
only have one dad
my dad was a preacher he was very strict
he was strict on some things he was not
strict on other things
uh but yeah he was very strict and he
wasn't a very good dad um i love him i
forgive him he's a human being now that
i'm older and i have kids i completely
understand where he's coming from
however he did things that i would never
do that i think
helped me to be a better father
you know in other words uh get rid of
the violence
you know that kind of stuff
uh so i learned here's what i
learned here's what here's what you need
to do as kids
and as growing up you learn from your
elders and i've always learned from my
elders i've taken wonderful things from
my mom who has experienced so many
things through life at the age of 86
uh especially like going through this
pandemic and everybody's scared to walk
outside and everybody's scared to do
this
here's a woman that lived through
smallpox and measles and hiding under
desk when they thought they were going
to get bombed by the
russians i mean she's and she was the
first one to go i don't get what
everybody's so scared about
it is you know what you live through
these things these are things that
happen every generation has and i get it
but yeah but uh so he just taught me how
to be i'm not a perfect dad but
uh i do my best and i learned
what we're supposed to do as we grow up
is learn from mistakes from other people
so you don't
do the same mistakes over again and
that's what i try to do in my life i try
to learn
from how i grew up and the mistakes that
my dad made i don't want to make those
mistakes
and so it made me a better father you
know a lot of people don't do that they
don't think about it they don't learn
and that goes for everything it goes for
uh our government it goes for the way
people live their lives it goes for as
you can tell right now our government
never learns
from the past they do the same things
over and over and over and wonder why
it's not working it helped in my it
helped me in comedy later on because i
was always the person that could uh
pop out a funny joke or a one-liner when
i needed it to lighten the mood up a
little bit it really taught me timing
when to throw in a joke what kind of
joke is perfect for this situation
what joke might cross the line a little
bit so i really learned a lot
from from uh from that kind of stuff you
know well you you say that life you're
supposed to learn lessons and some
people don't learn them that's totally
true but i think the layer that most
people
don't get to
because i think it's the hardest one is
to say i love my dad like i as a dad now
can understand him
so
how did you get to that point because i
think that's the hardest is to get to
actually truly get to that point of
forgiveness of love and to be able to go
wow maybe you can even gather that it
probably came from his dad right and all
of a sudden now you go i'm not going to
keep this pattern going and i'm i i love
you
right well you know since you asked i'll
tell you you know um i'm a christian i
believe uh i'm not religious i'm a g i
try to follow
uh the bible and jesus as much as i can
we'll never do it obviously because
we're never going to be perfect
but
he taught me how to forgive
and if he wouldn't have taught me how to
forgive i would never forgive him but
jesus forgave me he tells us to forgive
people
and so that's what you do you forgive
and my dad wasn't perfect but i forgive
you
oh
in the end when you think about it he's
a human being he had the same problems
the same struggles the same dumb stupid
stuff that other people do
and he you know so
i
forgive him and it's the most freeing
thing that you'll ever do in your life
to be able to get to the point to
forgive somebody that has done things in
your life
that really kind of messed you up a
little bit uh but man
when i tell people i honestly do i love
them i forgive him he was a human
um i'm not perfect i've done a lot of
stupid stuff i've probably in
relationships and probably hurt people
um as everybody hurts people in
relationships
and uh but the best thing you can do is
forgive
and uh it is a freeing free moment i
couldn't do it if i wasn't a christian
if i didn't believe in jesus christ
um i mean that's a guy that was hanging
on a cross that did nothing
but he never asked for any money
he never um begged anybody for anything
he never forced his beliefs
he never forced what he was teaching on
anybody
he gave everybody free will
and they did nothing but and they killed
him
they killed they killed a guy who did
nothing but want to be bring peace
and hope to the world
and they killed him and he looked right
at him and he said father forgive them
if he can do that so can i it makes me
think about
the way that the world is right now and
you're looking at
de-platforming cancel culture
things just
things being taken out of media and out
of our reach
because of certain reasons and it's like
he got taken out based on just living
his life and not forcing anything but
just
you know preaching
uh truth preaching his feelings and like
today we're seeing this all over the
place people i mean i don't even know
where you stand on this but as a
comedian i felt like you guys are like
the last ones that get to make all the
jokes and say all the things where the
hell do you land on that do you all of a
sudden have to approach your shows
differently
well
before i get to that uh he was the truth
and he was shedding light on darkness
and people don't want to have their
darkness uh light shined on their evil
deeds
and that's what's happening today
people don't want the truth being
being shown
on the evilness that they're doing and
what they're trying to do
and so they will ban
any form of truth
because they don't want the truth
uncovered and that's a fact if you were
really here's the thing if you are
really truthful
you don't want anything bad because you
can defend what you're doing
if you're telling that if you if you're
telling the truth if you're an honest
person you're telling the truth you can
defend it because it's true and it's the
truth
if you're not telling the truth
they don't want to hear it so they will
do everything they can to get the truth
off of there because it's shining a
light on their deeds and they don't want
that shine
that was the same thing
well that's the same thing with christ
he was he was shining a light
on all of their fraudulent bs
and they didn't like it
you know so they were con
just real quick they were controlling
back and then the religious leaders the
pharisees and the uh
they were controlling the people with
religion with their religion
and jesus was shining a light
on what they were doing
uh
you know because religion's all man-made
rules following christ is his rules no
man-made rules so you have you noticed
with religion and with man-made rules
the goal post always changes you always
have different targets to hit
jesus has one target to hit one goal
post one target you're never confused
there it is what is it with man yeah
with man you're you're trying to reach
all kinds of these oh make sure you just
do this you got to do this or you're not
going to you know and make sure that
your good deeds out do your bad deeds
that is completely
not anything that jesus talked about at
all what's that what's that one truth
what's that one truth that you anchor
with i am the way the truth and the
light no man cometh the father but
through me
and they didn't like that and that's
what he said
um as far as uh
as far as
comedy goes with the times that we're
living in today
um
it is tough
and uh
you know it's funny that bill maher i
have never
i'm one of those comics that like i like
all comedy comedy's hard and even though
a comic is
doing things that i don't agree with or
things that i would never do or say
i they have every right to do it and try
to find their own following it's called
capitalism it's called finding having a
doing what you do and having an audience
find you and like you
you know if you don't like the comedian
if you think he's doing this or he's
hateful or then don't go see
don't go see him he's out of your life
don't try to ban him from being able to
do what he does
i mean it's ridiculous
um i feel bad for the comics coming up
today because they have this whole
different standard and they have people
that are running the entertainment
business where if they don't like what
you say you're out of here
if they don't like what you do then
you're not going to get a break so you
better toe the line you better do jokes
that we find acceptable or you're not
going to be able to be comedian now the
comics that won't have a problem with
that are the ones that are already
established
the ones that already have a built-in
following where their audience tells
those people to go suck it
um you know i feel bad for the up and
coming comics because they're going to
have a hard time with that
um but that there are those of us still
out there that do comedy the way comedy
was intended to be
uh you know god gave everybody a
different sense of humor we all have
certain senses of humor
it's a gift why do why why were we
created with a sense of humor and a
different type of sense of humor because
when we were created god knew
what our personalities were going to be
like what we were going to be like what
what we think what we think is funny to
one person isn't funny to another person
what one person thinks is funny another
person doesn't think is funny i don't
know how many times
i have been around people
that have kids that have like
uh that are that are
crippled or whatever
or or someone uh and and their dad or
their
somebody will make it yeah you know
and they'll crack a joke about it you
know and you're thinking man why would
you crack a joke about you know why
because that's the way he deals with it
that's the way he can get through the
day
that's his sense of humor yeah he was he
was created with that sense of humor
because he was going to experience
situations where he would need that
sense of humor that's why we all have a
different sense of humor
to deal with certain things
i have a friend who i have a friend who
got cancer and he ended up having
to have a ball cut off and he's like all
the jokes you can possibly make about
this would be wonderful so it's like you
know let's go have a ball but just one
you know like he wanted him all that was
just his sense of humor and then there's
somebody else like you said who has
something happen and it's literally it's
just taboo we don't talk about it and
um you know that's that there's enough
if you're yourself there's enough people
number one i think that resonates with
people when you're just kind of being
yourself whatever that is but there's
plenty of people out there in the world
there's like eight billion people you
know and or i'm trying to think uh what
i think biden said there was 350 million
people in the country but there's like
320 right so you know there's 320
million people just in this country so
you know there's enough people that will
pay attention to what you're doing and
your sense of humor will resonate with
even if it resonates with you know a
couple percent that's a lot of people
absolutely i mean and it's uh it's it's
good laughter is good and rather youth
like that person laughing at something
that's not you to decide maybe that's
how he's dealing with something
you know you don't know
so mind your own business
it's like mind your own business yeah
well speaking of comedy changing um i uh
i'm fascinated with your comedy before
you were married to after you were
married and then with kids and um and
the fact that you would just like make
stuff up
before you were married because nobody
was going to know right you can make up
about a girl and it don't matter
right you clearly can't because you're
married now
um and my act i had like 90 ex-wives
um so
well first off have you ever made a joke
about me
have i made a joke about danica patrick
you know what i think i did i think uh
i what did i yeah i said that uh
danica patrick i go holy smokes
she's good i said she's good look and
now all the nascar drivers are gonna
have to have windshield wipers on the
inside of the car
and uh and then uh
what was in this i think another one
about pull setter but i can't remember
how it went
that's a good one on the pole danica's
yeah i think it was i think no i never
did that when it was something about
pole setter but it was for i think it
was i can't remember what it was for it
was
i can't remember so long ago
but i think i only did two or three of
them i'll tell you a funny story though
remember when we went down to
you and i
were like you were the grand marshal and
i was also doing something we were the
two big guests at the big race
louisiana i think it was
or no it was at the football game
yeah yeah yeah i was like at a rate i
probably wouldn't have been able to but
it was a bowl game that's right was it
in mobile alabama
yeah it was yeah and it was funny
because you and i were kind of hanging
out and then you went up you went up did
your deal then i mean you said a couple
of jokes about me and then i went up and
did my deal then a couple of natick
patrick jokes i think one of them might
have been windshield wipes on the inside
and anyway
and then
they they said some interviewed me but
we both said something nice about each
other and i just thought this was so
funny i was cleaning out my mail the
other day and i have stuff all the way
back from 2012 so i'm just getting rid
of stuff and i come across an article
from that thing
and it was some gossip column
in hollywood and it said
it said
could there be a new romance in the
making
and it said and it said the chemistry
between danica patrick and everything
and i was i was like oh my gosh i don't
even remember this article i showed my
wife and we just got into laughing about
it it was so hilarious that's amazing
i'm sure your wife has a good sense of
humor herself
comedian but i'm so cute
so
what would be an example like was there
some certain jokes before you were
married that would just like bring the
house down
that were total lies
oh my gosh absolutely or maybe based on
truth maybe
maybe just a small nugget of truth a
small nugget
but i would go yeah milo i'm you know
these are so far back
i'm trying to remember i've had like are
you larry are you larry in these jokes
oh yeah if i okay
if i can remember them
i'm trying to think if i can remember
from way back then now you're talking
about my first album that literally was
from like to
1999 or 2000
um i'm trying to remember some of those
jokes about yeah i dated this gal
uh
she had one boot bigger than the other
boob we got a wet t-shirt contest she
took first third place on that damn
thing and i told her
you know there's all kind i can't
remember that far back um
yeah mike what was one uh yeah my
sister-in-law
my sister-in-law got married last week
and
now she's pregnant she didn't tell her
husband
she didn't even tell her husband that
she was pregnant because he kind of
gotten used to or thrown up after they
had sex now so they can't
you know
but everything i made up all kinds of i
made up brothers i made up sisters i
made up
see that was the cool thing about back
then it was so freeing i mean i could
make up family members and and and
all that stuff and i had kind of did
have a little dilemma because when i got
married
i thought oh man
i don't want to be doing i'm out with
this girl last night or i was at the
strip club last week or i was you know
because that was like well
even if it's made up i don't want to
because i'm married now so i don't want
people to go
and we've already established from the
very beginning that you're a very kind
guy and that you like people to feel
comfortable so the last thing you want
to do is make your wife feel like she's
not important or not oh my gosh
i literally had to get rid of anything
like that i didn't do i did
ex-girlfriend jokes
i didn't do ex-wife jokes anymore
because everybody knew this was my first
wife
in real life and that's that was the
first time though danica that was really
weird for me because that was the first
time that the character
blended in with me with my real life
before
everything was fake
it was all made up it was larry the
cable guy i was writing for this whole
persona
now the persona
has just dipped into reality
in a way that's like yes there's some
like artistic freedom with being able to
make up these stories but it's it's like
it's like self-deprecating humor it's so
funny so now you're really telling
the truth kind of you know when you're
spinning it so what is something like
what's uh what's what's a joke that you
told afterwards that
um was like right on the limit of truth
and
you know i don't know something about
you something your wife does or you did
you do
or something like that where you're like
man this one hits but it's pushing it
oh my gosh um
something about you know sex after
marriage or
blow jobs anything like that no you know
what i didn't you stay away from that
i cut that stuff out i didn't want to
disrespect my wife wow you are
a good good person
i'm not a good person i cut it out
there might have been one or two but
honestly danica if i could remember i
would
we're talking
you know i do all one liner so i mean in
in a full 70 minute show i have 280
something punchlines
jokes
and i've had seven albums so that's you
know 2500 jokes
so it's i i really can't remember it's
the current stuff i can remember that
i'm doing now
but um i stay away i stayed away from
anything that i thought well that's kind
of mean i i don't want to do that like i
had one that i didn't do
um that i thought was i thought was
funny but it was like
well and it was uh
we were gonna film our baby's first
birth my baby when my baby was first
born we was gonna film the birth
but i couldn't get jessica simpson to
play the part of my wife
doing that you know and then i thought
well and then i'm thinking wait a minute
my wife's just as hot as jessica simpson
so why would i use you know
i mean seriously so then to me it wasn't
as funny and i'm thinking well wait a
minute now i'm making my wife sound like
a dog she's beautiful why would i yeah
so it was real that was the one hard
thing about uh
about my act because i tried to separate
it from me because i'm so different
in ways i'm not different in the fact
that
both the character is very country very
uh very rural very so am i
so that's the same kind of thing a lot
some people when they do a character
they did the opposite of the complete
opposite right
i didn't do the complete opposite i did
basically people that i grew up with and
friends that i knew is basically what i
did
so which were pretty much lived like i
did grew up like i did but said things
differently than i would say them and i
would no way would i have i would have
more tact
than than they would but that's when
everything started to bleed together and
then when i had kids it even bled even
more together
and um that's when critics and everybody
started saying that i became this
character that every time you see me i'm
larry the cable guy which is not true
because every time critics or anybody
would see me i was i was working i was
either doing
cars or i was
doing a show or i was so i was working
obviously i was going to be in character
i'm working i'm doing what i do
but out on the streets it was never it
was just always me it was just the same
kind of you know whatever i think that's
the thing with at with comedians like i
i remember like even david letterman he
was he owned the team that i drove for
him and bobby ray hall owned the first
indycar team i drove for and you know
there was this whole like
expectation level going out in public
that they knew which is like i'm
supposed to be funny i'm supposed to do
these things
and i i always think especially for
comedians um
that
i
how does that feel and you know you are
commuting some shorts in there but is
there
is that your
is that your on pressure like for me i'm
like you know you know i got in public
and you're supposed to be friendly and
nice and you do all the things but i
think it's like a more minimal
expectation level like just be a decent
man where with a role like that with a
job like that people expect you to just
floor them when you walk by and say
something
well that's the thing and that's where i
say that uh
where my
character comes in handy because like i
said
larry
the cable guy that i created i'm funny
uh he's funny too i i wrote for him to
be i created him to be funny as well but
he's a little more daring than i am
um so
that's uh that's where that all comes in
handy because people do you're a
comedian people do expect you to be oh
man he's funny you know and so that's
when boom it's not oh oh oh let that be
me myself i'm just myself but they'll
come up and they'll and so boom right
away i'll go
hey what's going on there with your heel
and then i'll dip down into something
and it doesn't even have to be a lot
also it has to be because i know they
like the movie cars and not like that
kind of stuff so hey there's some people
say hey what's up dan well the ones that
will say my real name oh hey what's
going on you know and the other ones
will go hey mate or what's you know i
get a lot of that they made what's going
on mater and i'll go oh tell you what
easy it's harder whatever blah blah blah
you know it's so cold outside today the
ice cream machine at mcdonald's was
working i'll tell you what
you know and then i'll dip down and do
that they laugh they go on their way
that's why sometimes i i always get
frustrated i mean they can do what they
want but comics that have been around a
while that have a certain catchphrase
or a certain thing that they did in a
movie they don't like to do it anymore
because they feel like they i don't
wanna you know what i mean it's like
jimmy jimmy walker hated saying dynamite
i get it i totally get it
um
sick of saying you might be a redneck
you might be a redneck are you like you
can't get her done
but it's just like jeff does the same
thing though
it doesn't hurt to give a real quick one
laugh and move on they're happy you're
happy you made somebody happy so that's
what i do is it sometimes a pain in the
neck absolutely but you know what hey
internet
and they're going away and then you and
you weren't a jerk
and plus i like people i honestly like
people i i enjoy people i like making
them happy
and so i don't mind doing things like
that but i definitely
dip down into the character a lot
when i'm when somebody expects me to be
funny because that's what i do that's
funny
you know that's what i do then when i
get to know them i can be myself and be
funny you know uh so but when i first
meet somebody i'm gonna crowd they
expect to be funny my defense mechanism
is always my default
is always hey hey you're not you know
that's always my default does it it
breaks the ice
makes everybody feel comfortable
and that's that's my that's my default
there you know what's
true for me right now is that you know
we've seen each other a few different
times and chad and whatever but
this is more of a real conversation than
we've ever had and
you're a really
i like i mean i like dan i like
you're you're smart you've thought about
things you're
compassionate
um
you're also convicted like i feel like
you have beliefs that are strong in all
different ways not just religious but
other ways too
and um
and so i'm really glad that this
conversation is
led so strongly with dan and
you know we didn't yeah because i really
like dan i mean yes larry makes people
laugh and these other roles make people
laugh but
you know it's uh it's magic
for comedians you can get people to fall
in love with you with a role but it's
really like the deep true love is is
comes through when you show who you
really are and so i'm glad we've had
you've been so open about so many things
you know you know what i'm always
i'm always open i'm always honest i
don't there's no need to lie to anybody
and you know when you said that it's
funny it reminds me of another person
that said that uh to me to me was uh
john lasseter from pixar
you know
uh
john when people ask me
um uh
john lasseter said to me that he loved
it that i voiced mate and he got to hang
around me because he said uh
not only does he he said the same thing
he goes man i love larry the cable guy
it's so funny he goes but i really like
hanging out with dan i really like dan
and he said
uh the closest you'll get to me and uh
with
is mater because mater is the larry
voice
the mater is my
is is my personality is my character
um i
i talked like larry the cable guy from
mater but when i came up with the
inflections and the hey me sally hey
like when i came up with all of the
heart stuff
that was basically i was just throwing
me into it just putting me into the
character
but i used the larry accent but that's
why john lasseter
that's what he loved about it he said
man i see both of you it made her after
hanging out with you i see both of you i
see the character and i see dan in mater
but it's just funny you say that because
he said the same thing
and uh and uh but you know hey i'm like
everybody else i'm not perfect i do my
best i i try to be kind to everybody
sometimes i sometimes you know it is
sometimes you just blow a top and you
got those days where you you lose your
self-control and yeah and you just got
to be alone and i have very few of those
days
um uh
but uh everybody does have those days
obviously i'm not perfect and i let me
say this as well to you
and this isn't a butt kissing session
for either one of us but i have to say
this for you because you said it's just
hard when you go out in public and you
have to do this and you have to do that
and i get it man i get it sometimes
there's nothing worse
than people
then you know what i mean if if i
sometimes if i could i would never leave
the house just to avoid
people sometimes you get in that mood
you know what i mean
but i'll tell you we went down to a race
i've been to a ton of races i've been
the grand marshal a bunch of times
but the last few times i've taken my
kids because they're old enough to enjoy
it but we were at that
race and we were at the race in kansas
city
and uh man you were so kind to my kids
my daughter
has been a danica patrick fan ever since
that day in kansas city
because you were so nice to them and
they were so they were just really
enamored
at how nice you were so they they both
said when they left their their
favorites for danica patrick and ryan
newman because they were so nice
oh
that's so sweet thanks for sharing that
story so so that's so you do do a really
good job at that
and i know a lot of times
what was taking a little extra time with
the kids because they can't reason like
an adult can reason and go you're
working or you probably have somewhere
to go but a kid doesn't really know you
know a kid
you know the kid just goes oh my my
favorite person just walked by and
didn't say anything to me or ignored me
or you know they weren't very nice you
know and that sticks and you also
they're so impressionable i mean the the
molding of a child i mean it's happening
most aggressively until about the age of
about six to eight and so to to have an
effect on a kid like that is is a really
cool thing and you know you were talking
about a lot about kids we're talking
about pixar and cars and i found it
amazing to hear just how
impressionable how meaningful
it was for you to be a part of pixar
versus let's say the blue collar comedy
tour which that's where i mean that like
puts you on the map i mean six years of
touring with you know a lineup of
amazing comedians i mean you know it it
made all i mean i remember watching it
as a kid you know it's it was a huge
deal but pixar is what hits home and i'm
wondering what why that is
oh man i'm so old you were a kid
watching this
um
i hear that about me too so hey people
are like people
you know even i feel like oh my god my
boyfriend even said he's like you know
when i met you i thought you would i
thought you were i thought you were
going to be a lot older like he's like i
didn't realize you'd be you were you
know in your later 30s i because he goes
because i remember being in high school
and you were a big deal and i'm like oh
my god
see that's awesome that he would say see
i get stuff like wow he's still alive
that's a whole different range
hey man we're just we're just just
climbing the ladder
oh my gosh now what was your question
it was just about pick sorry just you
know i'm wondering like what's the what
makes it hit home in your heart so much
that that is the thing that is the most
seemingly from what i have heard
really one of the most meaningful things
that you've done
well that's that's really meaningful
because uh first of all it's it's it's
an organization and they make movies
that every huge
a-list actor wants to do they all want
to do it for the kids or or
or their grandkids or they all want to
do a pixel movie so the fact i not just
got not only got picked to do a
character in one but it turned into
three and a theme park i mean it's
really a dream come true um i liked it
because it i had kids
and um i was able to bring in a whole
nother group of people that's why my act
started to change because i had kids
once you have kids
you start to think differently you have
different priorities it's not about you
anymore it's about your kids and you
want your kids to grow up good you want
you want them to give them a good
foundation you want them to see their
dad and some things that are really cool
that they so that's when i just started
re writing things differently
keeping the same thing neatly
the characters the character you can't
flip you know
but writing jokes that i'm more
comfortable with with kids
and since pixar came along uh that was
perfect
because i'd already started to adjust my
act and try to change everything and
then here came pixar but i think the
cool thing about it was john hired me
because of the voice he loved the voice
the voice was his tow truck
and i had worked so hard
on
on um uh developing this
and marketing myself
and doing these radio stations
uh for no pay a lot of them for years
no and just in the back of my say
wondering
at some point
this is going to have to lead to
something because it's getting more and
more popular it already led to the blue
color comedy tour
so you know
let's see what else happens and by gosh
i would have never dreamed when i first
did that voice on stage
when in 19
uh
probably
in the late 80s
never would i have dreamed that that was
the start of a pixar character i would
have never dreamed and it's just really
cool to see the development from the
very first time i went on stage the very
first time i went on stage that i'm a
big rodeo fan so i usually watch
yeah i used to watch mesquite
championship rodeo with donnie gay
uh on sunday nights
and uh i went on stage with a cowboy hat
one time because i used to do some
characters i just put a hat on and for
three minutes i went well we rode that
ball yesterday you took us up to pay
window you know i took the shot and
shorts but we win it that's what it
started with
got an okay laugh
the next day i went up and i did it as a
cable installer because i literally had
a cable installer come to our house in
florida
and he was just kind of a bumbling guy
that thought he had the wrong house but
he wasn't sure
and you know because the numbers on the
house but he and so i just went on stage
for the first time and i went hey uh do
you order cable
well somebody's ordered something here
because we've been driving around this
neighborhood uh 7 45
yeah well this is the house
you know and i literally did like a
three minute bed that got pretty good
but i would have never dreamed in a
million years that that night
that would have developed into
the character mater and so is that a
little guy does this cable guy know who
he is
i have no idea
he's probably dead now he was probably
70 40 years ago or however long it was
but
um yeah so it's just that's why it was
really cool it was just a culmination of
something that i created in my head
that just boom and that that's just a
cool feeling you know
um to go backwards in time then to the
in between from the birth of you know
this voice and doing stuff on the radio
and then all of a sudden you know you're
the voice of you know this huge
character in cars
uh is the blue comedy tour and blue
collar comedy tour
what was that like i mean i just
what is it like to have a room full of
comedians like i'm sure you guys are
i mean i think from my experience
sometimes people
don't realize that you might not
interact that much
right um
in certain environments like there'd be
times i go to the racetrack and you know
there's certain drivers that you
literally would only see in their car on
the track and you'd actually never see
them in passing and other points and
maybe during driver intros or something
like that but just for a split second
you don't hang out with them right but
people put them so what was it really
like like were you guys ever hanging out
or was there separation you know i know
foxworthy's flying in on his jet and you
know
you know doing doing doing the thing but
was there was there real camaraderie was
there not um how was it really well
first of all the funny thing about the
progression of blue collar comedy tour
was hilarious because
jeff flew in on the jet
we all flew in on delta
and then by the time the third one was
over
uh we left to go go home there was four
jets lined up
because jets are the best i know i'm
like sounds like i'm sure i sound like
such a dick right now but they really
are no they hey
absolutely i mean if you're blessed
enough to do it but here's the thing
about it people that what people don't
get about it
um
you don't take a jet unless there's
money on the other end you budgeted out
that when you want to take family trips
you can take x amount and take the jet
you don't want to do it if there's not
money on the other end but here's the
thing about the jet
uh people like these blue collar guys
flying around well you know what it's
pretty hard to get from michigan to st
joe to texas to florida in four days
on commercial airlines you can't do it
and it and you want to be you work so
much
you have to find a way to get somewhere
quick so you can be with your family
that's what it was all about believe me
if i could have saved money getting
somewhere quick a lot cheaper i'd have
done it but you can't do it and be an
entertainer and do 280 days on the road
and still spend time with your family so
yeah i was one of one of the things was
i was fortunate though a lot of those
times i had a the family truckster we
toured in a tour bus together
so uh on those blue colored dates where
we could get there in uh eight to ten
hours on the tour bus we would just take
the bus out and i'd be my wife and my
kids it was awesome but as far as the
thing goes you know what jeff and i have
been friends since 1986 he's like my
adopted brother i love him with omar
um i frequently very infrequently ran
into ron white i knew ron
i met him a couple of times he was
awesome he was my friend i mean he was a
nice guy funny but i'd only seen him a
couple of times i didn't know bill
lingball for squat never worked with him
didn't know him i just knew he was on
there so when i joined the tour
that was the first time i was introduced
to those two guys but as we progressed
and toured together in shows together we
were a tight-knit group we all were very
close to one another we had regular
little brother fights like you would
normally have little snippets here and
snippets there and get mad here at
something but in the end at the end of
the night it was all good we would never
let that go into the next day because
not only did we have something good
going we didn't want to ruin it but we
were truly friends and we did truly care
about each other and we knew that we
never
uh we never got jealous of the other
one's successes because we knew the
minute one person got
something good happened to them it was
going to happen to us
did we want it to happen to us first
well yeah maybe maybe we're like oh man
i hope i get that so well you know what
everything good that happens to one of
us is gonna is gonna happen to all of us
so so it was we always rooted each other
on it was great the camaraderie the
backstage we didn't sometimes some
weekends we would hang out all the time
we would go
uh
to breakfast we would
and then if it was just a one night a
week we would all fly in separate we'd
do our show hang out for that
hour backstage in the meet and greet go
home so yeah it's just like your nascar
nascar guys except we did hang everybody
about half the time that night we never
toured together on buses we did a thing
where it showed us a lot of bus together
we never did that
but as far as that goes those were some
of the greatest times of our lives
people always say will there ever be a
reunion of the blue collar comedy tour
and i gotta be honest
uh
it's really hard to replicate something
that was so special because you don't
want people going oh man that was really
funny but man i'll tell you what back in
the day those guys we don't want to back
in the day you know you can't you're
never going to top that uh
will you see us all four together one
time when we're in our 70s in vegas just
for a fun thing to do maybe
maybe not but as far as a big tour again
with us it's not going to happen for
somebody like you who's established and
had plenty of success and sells lots of
stuff oh yeah by the way you sell okay
hang on and look you sell
knives you sell camo head covers you
sell um like uh mixes like cake like
batteries like cornbread and breading
chicken and stuff that'll make your
toilet
hang on and you sell underwear
absolutely
is there a line that you've drawn in the
sand for like you know i'm not gonna
sell that
well no but no because nobody sells
brown colored underwear so it was a
perfect
i mean i sell only products that people
need
and should have
um you know here's why i do the products
um
i have a foundation to get it on
foundation we do a golf tournament to
help raise money for the foundation but
i thought it'd be cool what kind of what
else can we do what other kind of money
can we raise so in the first cars movie
i set by paul newman
and paul newman believe it or not people
wouldn't it's always funny who you see
who's the fan and who you think wouldn't
hear you or know your
paul newman man quoted a couple of my
jokes and was a fan said he thought i
was funny you know love my one-liners
which i was like holy mackerel and so i
picked his brain i told him what i was
doing and i picked his brain that night
we were eating at a steak house all the
pixar people uh for the first movie in
charlotte north carolina we were about
to have the thing and
i told him i wanted to be the redneck
paul newman does he have any tips and he
gave me awesome tips on how to get food
stuff out uh what he did to get food
stuff out how to work the internet how
to and that's what we did so all my
products go all my all my profits of
course people that make it they got to
get paid but
everything i make off of the food
products and knives it all goes to the
get it done foundation
and
yeah and so i that's why we did that
just to make some extra money for the
the get her done foundation i do have a
funny story about my food though right
when we first started that stupid
pandemic thing when they didn't let
anybody do anything for two weeks which
by the way is turned out to be a
disaster
um uh
somebody sent me a picture of three
boxes of
larry the cable guy hamburger helper
on the show that was it was a grocery
store completely empty on one whole side
but there were three boxes and so i i
retweeted it and i said
when you're in the middle of the
pandemic and the only food left or three
boxes of labor that came with a
hamburger helper it might be time to
retool
well i know actually the one i forgot
was your uh bloody larry mix i forgot
that because that's what i talked about
when you interviewed me for your show is
we talked about my wine and that you
make bloody larry mix
that one that sold out i'm sure because
drinking during the pandemic
especially early on was prevalent
right and just to show the difference
between you and me you're you're like i
know you love wine you're a winder and
you're selling wine i'm doing bloody
larry
and underwear
oh my god well the bloody larry mix by
the way is uh fantastic that stuff that
is really good stuff and it's uh doing
really well so that's that's awesome
congrats it's hard to do no matter what
yeah if you're trying to sell the market
is saturated everywhere and there's so
many ways to reach people about what
you're doing that even that's saturated
so
you're in the real tough market because
there's a lot of people doing wine and
there's not a lot of people doing bloody
mary mixes but there's a lot of people
doing wine
and your wine's doing very well correct
it is it is it's good and we just
launched a rose last year it's called
danica rose people thought it was the
first wine i did because insomniam which
is the napa valley wine the cab and rose
and sablanc they they didn't even really
know about that because they didn't have
my name on it so i mean i feel like i
got in the wine game i got in the wine
game in like 2009 i bought the property
so i feel like i was ahead of the curve
but yeah anyway
how big how big are the how big of boxes
can you get
uh 12
12
does it come in the box the 12 ounce
boxes
no
you've seen wine in a box right oh that
kind that kind
yeah right over my head yes i have i'm
sure i've drank it before and then i
don't remember
the only wine joke i ever wrote was uh
valentine's day is uh all about the
women it's all about their special day
so
be courteous and if you if you if you
have to fart make sure you time it with
the wine court
and then i said
i said i bet we went through eight
bottles of wine
[Laughter]
that's how classy i am danica oh my god
that's so fantastic well larry you're a
wonderful sorry larry dan um
now that we're now that we're real
friends um
it's a pleasure
thank you this was nice because i mean
we're running at each other all the time
so this is great
i know i know well next time i see you
i'm gonna say hey dan
and uh
then we're gonna we'll be we'll pick up
where we left off in the meantime maybe
i'll come see you on your tour i would
love to come see you perform yeah man
that would be awesome just you know you
know always check my uh later the
cableguy.com my twitter my all my social
media i'll tell you where i'm at and if
you say hey dan when we're in public you
say dan i'll turn around and go hey
what's going on man it's a good time
today i've never seen
well if i see you at a show probably
but if i see you at starbucks or
something else maybe not no it'd be
completely normal trust me
all right well thank you very much dan
and um yeah everybody can come watch you
watch you perform and and uh play all
your roles that people love
that's awesome hey danny thanks for
having me on this is a lot of fun i
enjoyed it and good luck to you and all
you're doing can i do one of these
before i leave sure
yeah get her done
gotta sign off for the gator donna
yeah obviously
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button